what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich
the rest of us trying to get out of here
in your vest you're like a wall street
pro don't forget the lunch money is now
supposed to buy block five block five
has three products you can buy and sell
crypto on their crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan against
your crypto collateral or you can earn
up to eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account block
five dot com slash
block five.com
what's up hey i know my hair's a little
crazy today
all right real crazy like a little
bird's nest go ahead
okay u.s consumer prices increase
solidly in february as the cost
of gasoline rose further leading to the
biggest annual gain in the year but
underlying inflation remained tepid
amid sluggish demand for services like
airline travel
what do we think you can't say that
inflation doesn't go up if the prices of
things are going up
what is going on here literally the
labor department said on wednesday
it's consumer pricing index cpi the
official
metric increased 0.4
last month in one month it went up 0.4
and the month before that it went up 0.3
in the 12 months through february the
cpi gained 1.7
the largest rise since february 2020
after climbing 1.4
in the month 12 months through january
so my fellow
friends come on don't do the voice
inflation
is happening it may not
be 20 inflation but you can't say
there's
no inflation prices are slowly creeping
up
and we're about to put another 1.9
trillion dollars
so maybe the bitcoiners are right
let's go ahead okay um okay so
just weeks after jpmorgan chase
publisher report warning that
traditional financial companies are at
risk of falling behind in digital
finance
jpmorgan chase is looking to issue debt
linked to
cryptocurrency focused companies
so it created the jpmorgan
cryptocurrency exposure
basket the incoming debt instrument is
long on microstrategy square
riot blockchain and chipman chipmaker
nvidia
nvidia this is what i call a cop-out
jp morgan you think this stuff's real
then get in the game
get in the game you think this stuff is
just a marketing exercise
then you do things like this you create
a basket
of companies some of them have lots to
do like microstrategy
some of them have nothing to do with it
nvidia
majority members has nothing to do with
crypto well
the majority of your business has
nothing to do with crypto so
here's the deal if you believe then
believe
and do actual things go buy bitcoin go
facilitate trading lending deposits et
cetera
if you don't believe you do stuff like
this because you basically want
oh look look at this great thing we have
exposure i think i think it's a step in
the right direction it's
it's they're going to move slowly but
aren't you happy that they're moving in
that direction
sure but i don't celebrate baby steps i
celebrate
big boy steps so let's go jp morgan it
looks like jamie dimon changed his mind
too go ahead roblox
it's uh it goes public
today um and it turned
so that there is a story about how the
indie game makers turned the company
into a 30
billion dollar behemoth
roblox almost tripled payouts to
developers last year while revenue
didn't quite double
as the company aims to get top creators
to spend more of their time
building for the app so roblox is really
cool because it's popular with kids
teenagers whatever
but you can actually become a developer
on the app and create
games and make money from it listen
this is a massive business that snuck up
on a lot of people it's knock-up
but if you are a parent and you have
kids you know about roblox facts
it's gonna only continue to i think this
is a great business we'll see how it
does in the public markets
but gaming ain't going nowhere go ahead
next
jack dorsey um who announced on tuesday
that bidding on the first tweet
ever uh sent that
will end on march 21st and he will
accept the winning bid
donating the proceeds to charity he's
donating it
to um um uh
the covid 19 africa response campaign
and the program is just under five
million dollars short of its goal
so it's it's give directly a non-profit
organization that specializes in giving
direct
cash transfers to low-income people he
gonna convert it's a bitcoin
bitcoin and then he's gonna send it i
love it
because he says it in the original tweet
oh he's gonna convert it to will
immediately convert proceeds to bitcoin
that's awesome
and then he's gonna send it so let's
roll jack always
leading the charge dubai airport
so dubai's airport the world's busiest
for international travel
uh is looking to roll out another
edition from the realm of science
fiction
an iris scanner that verifies one's
identity and eliminates the need for any
human interaction when entering leaving
the country
so instead of passports you'll be able
to scan your irises i
iris i receive iris
and go through the airport i just fought
off the yawn but the angle gonna be
scared of my eyes you don't need to see
these eyes it's like looking to me i am
the captain now
now they ain't getting my eyeballs why
do they need to do that just read my
passport it's fine
i'm right here here's my documentation
all right guys it's ask
lunch funny time hashtag ask lm in the
comments below
this one comes from sabrina kaze kazen
hi guys my boyfriend and i watch you
guys daily and see so much of a
resemblance between your personalities
relative to us
sabrina i am so sorry oh you have to
deal with
your boyfriend who's acting like him um
so they love lunch money her boyfriend
doesn't know she's commenting but if we
see this her name is sabrina and his
name is
sebkar ah i know you have both
studied up on some of the most
successful individuals who are your role
models
or your favorite profiles all right so
um
i'm gonna i'm gonna mention one that i
published today that i thought was super
interesting it's on dolly parton
a woman who she is a country singer
writer producer
songwriter uh businesswoman she is
wildly
underestimated but she has done
so much in her life um she is 75 years
old she has a theme park she's got
numerous businesses she knows real
estate
she owns publishing rights to many of
her songs that have blown up
um she created the imagination library
which donates free books to children all
over the world because her dad couldn't
read or write so she wanted to help
people
she's just a really really cool person
and i think
people underestimate her a lot but she
is actually
a savage i like the guy who made up the
hot flaming cheetos
oh yeah robert uh no um
oh we don't forget his name but there's
a guy he created hot flame and cheetos i
like him
he probably is my favorite person uh but
i need to
say one thing real quick sabrina my name
is richard montagnes
yeah richard montenez uh sabrina listen
i appreciate you writing in the comment
but i just want you to know
you are very lucky you are very lucky
why is the man like he's
kind he's caring he's funny he's
charismatic he's rich
like you are so lucky sabrina that he
on a daily basis that he on a daily
basis
enjoys your company so i appreciate you
always being so kind to him but you're
very lucky i just want you to know that
go ahead
all right moist counter moist moist
today is day 20 i think man it's been a
while
still got 70 more days to go so he says
i have a ghost
that lives in my apartment so clearly he
believes in ghosts
i'm fairly close to a funeral home so i
imagine the ghost wandered over from
there
my roommates and i named him charles
he's pretty chill all he really does is
knock stuff over on empty rooms or
jiggle the locks
i've yet to have an encounter with a
hostile ghost they usually just seem to
want attention
yeah they're just like little kids you
know they'd be jiggling locks they'd be
knocking things down what do you think
moist it sounds like your ghost
is similar to my wife
i'm gonna knock your head down she'd be
knocking things over
jiggling the locks
next question from moist what is your
question
moist have you ever worn
two different socks at the same time
and not realized that you had two
different socks on
but then realized that at some point
during that day tell me the story
okay we have a moist twist
ready lunch money viewer who i
personally really enjoy
her name is gabriella she goes hashtag
ask lm sessions have become the new
tinder
so how old is moist again she's kidding
just kidding
oh wait jokes aside it's a nice touch to
interact like this with your audience
you're moist
moist gabrielle's off gabriella
i think it's how you say it just get on
the google machine my wife can help you
she is the greatest
you're not setting people up with
moisturizing moist
listen you and i both know when the
iron's hot you strike
just there you go go in the comments
check it out 20 hours ago it was posted
i have a feeling moist is in college i
don't know personally how old gabrielle
is but like
just why do you think he's in college he
said he was like finishing an exam or
something
he's 20 years old he's an expert he's an
expert he might be
teaching the college class all right see
you guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block live is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but eight point
six percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends